do you remember the rumored PS5 slim
with a detachable disk drive well there
seems to be a bit more info on what it
could possibly be according to Insider
Gaming's Tom Henderson the possible PS5
slim doesn't seem to have any major
Hardware changes from the original
console Tom also said that the disk
drive might not work with current
Digital Editions if that's true then
this is a very odd decision for Sony to
make the internals are identical so
someone correct me if I'm wrong but
shouldn't the current digital console
just need a firmware update I'm not
interested in buying one I do love the
Digital Life despite its shortcomings
but for those that are maybe a third
party will end up making some as well
then current digital edition users can
be the proud owners of a madcats PS5
disk drive this new PlayStation 5 with a
detachable Drive was first reported in
September of 2022. the system will
supposedly arrive in September of 2023
and has been in production since
November of 2020. the disk drive will
connect to the console through a USBC
port in the back of the system Sony will
reportedly sell the Slim system on its
own or bundled with the detachable Drive
which itself will also be offered
separately but no matter which version
of the PlayStation 5 you own your
priority is most likely games followed
by your dwindling storage space one game
a bunch of you will be making room for
later this year is Rocksteady Suicide
Squad kill the Justice League this week
a leaked image for the game has
confirmed that it will have several live
service elements verified by VGC the
image first appeared on 4chan and is
said to be from a recent test build like
other games in the live Services field
Suicide Squad will have its own battle
pass system that is focused on cosmetics
and a currency for each hero that can be
used to customize their individual skill
sets players who are concerned that
Deadshot Captain Boomerang Harley Quinn
and king shark will be entering
Metropolis in an underpowered State when
the game starts while won't have much to
worry about as an internal source told
VGC that the game has a power up curve
similar to Batman Arkham Knight for
reference Arkham Knight's Batman started
off with all the usual tricks of the
trade and has the game wore on could
unlock skills and gadgets that allowed
him to deliver absurd amounts of offense
one platform you won't be able to play
Suicide Squad on is stadia because the
cloud service will officially take its
last breath tomorrow January 18th many
games will still allow you to transfer
your data from the cloud service onto
another platform however Destiny
publisher Bungie warns that players who
fail to set up cross save before
Wednesday will lose almost everything so
definitely get on that before you lose
all those sweet eververse purchases do
you have a PS5 yet and how often do you
play it let me know in the comments and
we'll see you tomorrow
foreign